so glenn yonkin is running for governor
of virginia as a republican he's found
himself right in the middle of this
debate he could win on tuesday he joins
us tonight glenn young thanks so much
for coming on so it i don't think
anybody at the beginning of this race
thought it would be about this question
do parents should parents have any
influence over their own children
um were you surprised that there it
turns other people who think that
parents don't have a right to influence
their own kids
well tucker thanks for having me tonight
and no i'm not surprised because
virginia's parents and particularly in
loudoun county where it's been ground
zero they've been trying to stand up for
their kids for the last 20 months open
our schools stop teaching our kids what
to think and teach them how to think
make sure we understand what's going on
in the classroom and my opponent he
stood there and said no parents do not
have a right to know what's going on in
the classroom and in fact he doubled
down on and tripled down and quadrupled
down on it and then just yesterday you
know he was with he was with president
biden yesterday and and i'm sure they
discussed this he could have told
president biden president biden i'm i'm
siding with parents because in virginia
by the way parents have a legal right to
make decisions with regards to their
children's education it's a legal right
in virginia and terry mcauliffe told
president biden if he had if he could he
did he didn't
they should change that but what
happened today was of course merrick
garland
he doubled down he said no
i'm absolutely maintaining my position
that the doj and the fbi should be
investigating parents parents who are
trying to stand up for their children
when there's been a sexual assault and a
school bathroom and we have a board of
educate we have a board of education in
loudoun county that tried to hide it
from parents hide it from hiding from
the public and they moved this child
into another school
and then that child again committed
another sexual assault
i've called for a full investigation
i've called for an investigation of the
school board the commonwealth attorney
the state superintendent yeah i'll tell
you the attorney general of the united
states should resign and oh by the way
the fbi should be investigating these
folks too
this is just absolutely un-american and
as governor in virginia i'm going to
stand up for parents i'm going to stand
up for children i'm going to stand up
for the fundamental rights for parents
to make decisions with regards to their
kids education
this has absolutely got to stop and
that's why i'm running tucker because
it's time for individual liberty to to
win over big government control and my
opponent terry mcauliffe he believes in
big government control and i believe in
parents rights when it comes to their
children's education to make decisions
for them
i mean what they're really saying is
we're your children's parents and you're
not and i and on the basis of that alone
we are rooting for you glenn younkin on
tuesday in virginia thanks so much for
coming on the show tonight tucker thank
you for having me this is this is a big
moment for america too hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else